[Music]
we were so excited when you got a chance
to go to Oregon dizzy we just knew that
Evie had to pick you after all you are
practically her little sister I can't
believe I get to live with you in your
very own job you might have spent most
of descendants 3 under a sleeping spell
but there is a lot more to you than
meets the eye and we are here to clear
up all the reasons you're such an
awesome character dizzy Jermaine is one
of the newest V caves in Oregon
check out these theories and connections
that no one realized about dizzy family
business when we first meet dizzy in
descendants - she works in her
grandmother salon we don't meet lady
tremaine until the third movie but she
seems to treat dizzy a lot like she
treated Cinderella dizzy is responsible
for doing all the cleaning and she gets
yelled at - but a relationship with her
grandmother is way more complicated than
that we don't get to see a lot of
interaction between them but here's what
we know from descendants three it seems
like Lady Tremaine is the main parental
figure - disease disease ma mr. Saleh
and her aunt is Anastasia but we never
see Cinderella's two wicked stepsisters
when dizzy is ready to leave the aisle
her mom and aunt are nowhere to be seen
but her grandmother is there to say
goodbye to her lady tremaine is super
strict but dizzy loves her she gives her
a big hug this family obviously doesn't
like to show affection Lady Tremaine is
totally taken aback by the gesture their
relationship may not be perfect but
there is definitely love there but why
don't we see Drizella
well let's be honest Drizella is not cut
out to raise a kid don't you remember
how childish and awful she was in
Cinderella Lady Tremaine has raised two
daughters so she's the obvious choice
when it comes to raising dizzy dizzy is
also related to someone from auradon
they don't mention this in the movie so
you might not have noticed but dizzy is
related to Chad charming Dizzy's mom
Drizella was the stepsister of
Cinderella chad is the son of Prince
Charming and cinder
Rella that means that chad and dizzy are
cousins
well technically their step cousins but
there are lots of blended families that
don't make that distinction does he act
more like the sweet Cinderella we know
and love and Chad is so spoiled he acts
more like Drizella did these two should
have switched parents we bet that dizzy
and Chad will connect and Cinderella
will be the awesome aunt that dizzy
deserves the next Eevee I would like to
begin with the granddaughter of Lady
Tremaine each of the core four got to
pick the next generation of decays to
come to Oregon our original villain kids
are just about done with school
they picked kids that really resonated
with them J and Carlos picked squeaky
and squirmy because no one expected much
from those boys no one ever expected
much from Carlos and J either but they
believed in the smead twins now picked
Celia because she is the baddest kid on
the Isle and Evie picked Izzy because
they're so similar they're definitely
the sweetest of the villain kids they
see the good in people and being mean
just doesn't come naturally to them
Susie is also a fashionista just like
Edie Edie brought her fashion design
skills to ward on Perez dizzy will bring
her awesome salon skills we expect to
see some awesome hairstyles at the
school now no magic needed
she's also talented at making the
accessories like Edie's tiara from
descendants too
Evie respects Dizzy's talents we think
these two will end up in business
together after dizzy graduates Edie
love's dizzy they're just like sisters
Dizzy's mom got to grow up with a sister
but dizzy is an only child and she
didn't get a lot of affection at home
but she did from Evie Evie was the
person who believed in dizzy
she was always quick to hug her and
encourage her Evie wanted to be in
auradon because she knows she belongs
there she's smart and kind and talented
and now dizzy can be the pool loving
older sister to this me twin
and other decays why dizzy didn't fight
after meeting dizzy in the second movie
we expected her to have a much bigger
role in descendants 3 but we really
didn't get to see too much of her
mal tells her to stay with the twins
dizzy squeaky and squirmy all fall under
Audrey sleeping spell
so why didn't does he fight she might be
like Eevee in a lot of ways but there is
one important difference
dizzy doesn't know how to fight most of
the villain kids learned how to fight
from their parents but Disney's family
wasn't particularly skilled in combat or
Savion magic dizzy didn't have anyone
tough to show her the ropes
if dizzy had gone to the aisle with
mousy Leah and the rest she wouldn't
have fallen under the sleeping spell but
she would have been in way more danger
dizzy stay here to take care of the
twins we'll be right back and everything
will be just fine go inside
mal and Evie wanted to protect her and
dizzy wasn't even upset about it you
don't have to be tough to be a VK dizzy
just knows that she has her strength
she's responsible and caring still part
of us wishes that dizzy had been a more
prominent figure in descendants 3 do you
think dizzy made the right choice by
staying in Oregon or could she have
helped the vks throughout their quest
tell us in the comments and be sure to
tell us what you love about dizzy while
you're at it thank you for tuning in
give this video a big thumbs up and
subscribe to the things for more great
content we'll catch you next time
[Music]
[Music]